five years ago as I entered a stage of
my life in which passing along what I've
learned became my most important goal
I shared my principled Approach along
with my collection of life and work
principles in a book
I was shocked by its impact it's been
translated into 34 languages and sold
more than 4 million copies worldwide and
an animated video based on it principles
for Success has been watched by more
than 40 million people maybe most
importantly to me over these five years
I've had thousands of great interactions
with people who told me how
life-changing the principled approach
was for them many asked me for advice to
help them come up with their own
principles and that's brought me to this
point
looking ahead while I will continue to
share my principles for a bit longer
until I put out my next book and video
on economic and investment principles
now I'd like to help you come up with
your own principles and build your
collection of the best principles from
the most successful people in the world
that's why I've created a guided Journal
that you can pre-order from Amazon or
your favorite local bookstore and it
will work together with the free app
that will help you do that so you should
think hard about what are your
principles and how do you going to use
those to get what you want out of life
I want to help you do that I look
forward to this new phase in our
relationship